Speaker 1: Guys, this this next story is is
pitiful. Ever since the of all the shooting,
there's been a spike in the discussions,
rightfully so, about gun control and. That
means many more Republicans than usual are going
to have to be asked why they stand in the way
of any common sense gun reform. And shockingly
enough, a host on Fox News actually asks Senator
Mike Lee a really good question, and she shows
polling on the support for a number of these big,
main common sense gun reforms that people
push for and shows just how wildly popular
they are. And then asks Senator Mike Lee. Aren't
you out of step with your constituents? If
these items, these proposals are this
popular, let's look at how it responds.
Speaker 3: Behind some of these proposal. At
this at this point, some of these proposals,
background checks for guns, which by and large,
most of them are background checks before you do
a purchase. 88%, though, moving the legal age for
an assault rifle purchase is at 82% flagging for
people who are a danger to themselves or others as
red flag laws 81% and banning assault weapons 63%.
There is a lot of momentum, at least among the
public sphere, for doing this. Are you out of
step with your constituents? Okay. So first
of all, what's important is that we look out
for the rights of constituents. Constituents are
asked poll questions. They're not asked questions
about specific language within legislative
text. It's the job of a lawmaker
to look out for the interests and the rights of
the law abiding citizens they represent. And so
with each of those provisions, I understand how
they could get high popularity ratings when they
don't define them. For example, you talk about
banning assault weapons. There is no universal
definition of what an assault rifle is. Very
often the true distinction, it really depends
on whether the stock pieces of the gun are
made of wood or a plastic or a composite.
And so the text does matter here because it's that
text that will determine whether we're intruding
unduly on the rights of the American the American
law abiding citizen, and doing so in a way that
would actually deter violent criminal behavior.
Speaker 1: So first off, even though this
is not something we should have to do, journalists
should always be this way. I want to thank the Fox
News host for actually asking a real question.
And I just want to make sure you guys don't get
at all misled about this, because I
think we have a tendency when someone's
on television and they finish a complete sentence
and then look at the camera confidently, we go,
Oh, dang, they successfully dodged the question.
But no, that entire clip, he said a lot of words
with zero substance. He goes on and on about
the text of the bill. The text of the bill?
Yes. That's your job. You're a legislator.
Your job is to take general proposals that
are popular in the country and then are
popular among your constituents at least,
and then implement them. And throughout that
process, you work out the specifics of the bill.
You work out the details that you are referring
to as the text of the bill. We all recognize
that universal background checks is a little
bit more complicated than just writing down on
a bill. Universal background checks go right. We
understand that you don't need to say that to us,
but you should as sure as hell should not be
using it as an excuse for not acting on the issue.
There's a lot of specifics that we don't know
about yet. Well, get working, buddy. His answer,
of course, should have been, I absolutely support
those proposals you just put on screen. As you
mentioned, they're both popular and they would
save lives and they don't infringe on our rights.
All I want to do now is work on the
nuts and bolts of this legislation.
And then we'll be able to accomplish the goals set
out by those more general positions that you just
outlined. But instead, he gives the weakest and
laziest answer to get out of genuinely answering
why he doesn't support the reforms that would save
lives, as I mentioned, and would be in line with
his own constituents. He didn't even answer her
specific question, really, which was, are you out
of line with your constituents? Yes is the answer
to that question. He said effectively, Oh, well,
the reason is his constituents aren't able to look
out for their own rights. That's his job. Well,
know your constituents understand by that
polling that it's not an infringement on
the right to regulate firearms in a common sense
way. And I honestly don't know how people like
Mike Lee feel good about themselves after giving
an answer that's that slimy and that dishonest.
You gave that answer to protect the gun
lobby and this delusional idea that any
form of regulation and trying to implement
any common sense gun reform is revoking the
Second Amendment or something. And I know this
sometimes comes off as a little bit hyperbolic,
but honestly, how do people like Mike Lee live
with themselves knowing all of these tragedies
are going to happen in the future or another? Not
all of them, but a number of tragedies are going
to happen in the future because we didn't act now.
And he's one of the people standing in the way,
giving dishonest answers like that to. For really
no good reason. And it's going to cause these
tragedies. And I really don't know how people
like him live with will live with themselves